Samantha's in New York they've recently
switched companies and in my role I pay
for a lot of client meals and events
usually about $1,000 a month in the past
I've always had a company credit card
for these expenses but with this new
company I'm required to pay for it on my
own upfront my question is is it worth
it to get a personal credit card no no
first thing I would do is walk in there
and just go guys I'm really not in a
position to be the bank for this big
company and loan you guys money every
month or go in debt on your behalf so
you guys need to furnish me a credit
card that's the first thing I would do
now if that doesn't work what I would do
is get a separate debit card a separate
two checking account just for business
expenses and I put $1,000 in that
account and then you would use that
thousand dollars to buy the stuff that
you're supposed to be buying only for
business only reimbursable expenses then
you would get the thousand auto
reimbursement back and put the thousand
back it will not cost you anything
except you had to post the first
thousand dollars to prime the pump and
after that then you know you're just
going to turn in your receipts because
you're not going to use this account for
anything except business expenses that
are reimbursable that's the only thing
you would consider doing and you know
you just you're gonna get caught into
stuff here Samantha that's just stupid
people do this all the time I'm gonna
take out a credit card just use it for
business expenses and then they don't I
don't it runs up and they end up with a
balance on the stupid thing because they
bought stuff that was not reimbursable
expenses and then their stock and I know
you think you're not gonna do that let
me tell you the number of people that do
the thing you're talking about doing it
and do it all the time is almost zero
almost everyone abuses this card and
don't put yourself in a position that
you have to be like superhuman in your
discipline in order to win a silly
you play with snakes you will be bitten
some people are better at playing with
snakes and others but at the end of day
everyone that plays the snakes
eventually gets bitten and that's true
with credit cards there's snakes credit
card companies are snakes don't be a
snake handler it's when it comes down to
just don't go there number one this
company ought to be furnishing you the
if then it amazing that corporate
America has run such con on its
employees the employees all over the
nation are running around acting as a
bank for these big companies loaning
them money to operate their businesses
and then the company then they pay the
bill every month most of the time but if
they don't pay the bill you know who
gets to pay the bill don't you you it's
your stupid credit card
[Music]